As the sun's magnetic
field ripples out, it
twists and tangles.
The lines criss cross
and reconnect, forming
giant magnetic bubbles.
Each foamy sphere bubble
thing is about 100
million miles across,
which is tremendous.
That's the distance from
the earth to the sun.
And there are thousands
of these surrounding the
solar system.
No one is sure what these
magnetic bubbles do, but
it's possible that this
cosmic bubble wrap is the
first line of defense
against galactic
radiation, helping
protect the solar system
from the cosmic
onslaught.
Think about how much
technology has changed
since Voyager was
launched, and today no
one had phones in their
pockets.
I mean, no one could
even make long distance
phone calls across the
ocean without it being a
tremendous ordeal.
But yet with this old
technology, we're now
learning about the very
edge of our solar system.